go to SeaWorld boy it's so important to
protect them the few untouched tribes
left indeed yes and while we're on the
subject I've got something of a
confession to me oh dear
while I was down there I caught the
attention of a young Masai woman who did
she took me for an exotic sophisticated
Superman of sorts and developed
something of a liking to me there's
quite awful Jerrold she came down to my
heart wearing nothing but a fertility
headdress and carrying a husband I had
to participate in I remember several
years ago when I went to the Amazon in
the entire village
yes which is in Papua New Guinea
introduced the local tribe to the French
term ménage a trois
after that evening a couple of the local
men called me Papua oh dear
oops-a-daisy
whoopsie-daisy indeed it's getting
harder and harder to protect the local
tribes from the influence of the outside
civilization I know exactly what who
exactly but I must confess that the last
time I was deep with the borscht in
Australia yes I ended up deep in
[ __ ] oh yeah well where are you off
to now or I am I'm off to Tanzania
that's beer make sure that you go during
an eclipse because then everyone will
want to have sex with you
you